else's immortality will be an essential
pop point in frozen three from helping
honest kids to complicating Elsa's
romantic relationship / immortality will
be key
keep watching to the end to discover
what new ally will finally give Elsa the
partnership fans have been calling for
well actually it bridge has two sides
and mother had two daughters now that
Elsa is immortal
frozen three will definitely up the
stakes when you're in everlasting
spirits the normal challenge of mere
mortals don't apply to you Elsa doesn't
have to worry about her personal fate
anymore so that frees her up to focus on
helping others we've got the theories
you want to hear about just how
important Elsa's immortality will be in
the third movie what grave danger could
on a face and how could Elsa help save
her what evil forces might descend upon
arendelle or the enchanted forest
what might enraged the other four
elemental spirits then cause earth fire
air and water to become destructive
again and what will Elsa's immortality
mean for her own personal relationships
could she get involved with a mere
mortal like honey Marin or will she meet
another immortal spirit in human form
just like her to form a romantic
partnership with now that Elsa has been
transformed into her immortal state in
Auto Hollen she stand alone in a unique
position
she's an elemental spirit in human form
so we can be sure the responsibilities
will rest squarely on her shoulders when
would ever major event hits unless she
finds an important ally you'll want to
keep watching to discover who that might
just be keep looking after the forest I
love you
anna and kristoff seemed to get their
happily ever after at the end of frozen
to the third movie could very well start
with their wedding ceremony then we
could skip forward a few years to the
pair being proud parents and this is
where Elsa's immortality might be
crucial we've already seen the links
Elsa will go to to protect her sister so
we can just imagine how protective she
would be of her nieces and nephews the
peril levels would skyrocket if the
youngest generation were the ones in
trouble on an Kristoff would surely
place their children in the care of Elsa
in the enchanted forest but what might
the danger be perhaps Anna and Kristoff
themselves are battling against an
illness that they don't want to pass on
to their children with Elsa bein
immortal they wouldn't have to worry
about her health deteriorating she could
become the children's guardian and to
look after them for as long as it took
the what if the threat was over the
entire kingdom of arendelle and not just
its Queen arendelle has had to face
various dangers before in the first
frozen movie Elsa inadvertently set off
an eternal winter in the sequel the
spirits angrily toured through arendelle
and then there was an epic wave from the
dam being destroyed so we've seen that
it can survive terrifying situations and
that would mean that whatever evil force
it had to face in the third movie would
be on an epic scale perhaps that illness
that took hold of Anna and Kristoff had
spread to all the inhabitants Elsa would
be the only one who wouldn't be affected
by it given that she's immortal so she
would have to work with an authority
Elsa could deliver it and treat the sick
she would be immune to any ill effects
so she'd be the perfect medical helper
in that situation I don't want to put
anyone at risk again and you're right on
these external threats are terrifying
but what if the danger came from within
that's super spine-chilling and we've
already seen how destructive before
elemental spirits can be Elsa was able
to tame them individually she made
friends with Bruni after using her ice
powers in a battle with a fire spirit
when they first met she's on such good
terms with Gale that the wind spirit
passes letters between Elsa and Anna and
after a rocky start also literally
reined in not the water spirit in horse
form of course Anna had her part to play
in calming the spirits to which she did
by breaking the dam she was able to
restore peace between arendelle and the
enchanted forest but that doesn't mean
the earth fire air and water spirits
won't become vicious again there could
be a threat to the enchanted forest that
sends them into a rage and only Elsa can
stop them as she needn't fear for her
own safety because she's immortal I
promise you I will free this forest and
restore the enchanted forest is
precisely that enchanted and magic is
very alluring as pabbie has previously
warned so it makes sense that when word
gets out about the magic contained
within the forest people will come
looking for it and attempt to invade the
enchanted forest to gather up the magic
for their own evil plans
that's certainly enough to enrage the
four elements of spirit fighting that
actions with bad actions isn't the way
to win Elsa knows this from personal
experience it would be impossible for
the other spirits to negotiate with the
invaders but as Elsa is in human form
she could stand up to the enemy in a way
that no one else could with no need to
worry for her own safety
Elsa could be right on the front line
but there is a [ __ ] in Elsa's immortal
armor and that's the people she loves
whilst she can't be harmed her loved one
certainly could be and that could cause
some serious issues for Elsa my fault
I was looking for answers about me
in both the frozen movies Anna has been
the sister to have romantic
relationships she's been involved with
both Hans and Kristoff Elsa on the other
hand has had other concerns like how to
control her ice powers in the first
movie and then how to find the voice
calling out to her in the second film
but fans have been begging Disney to
give Elsa a love interest and there's
been plenty of speculation about who
that could be many fans are wondering if
Elsa could get involved with a member of
the Nostalgia tribe now that she's
living in the enchanted forest
the two main contenders are Ryder and
honey Maren
but given that Elsa is now immortal
could she really get involved with a
human surely that would create problems
for the two of them further down the
line it could also create major problems
for the whole of the enchanted forest
after all the only way to get someone to
like Elsa to surrender is by attacking
and threatening their mortal loved ones
if an enemy comes to the forest to steal
the magic they could very well use
else's love interest as a bargaining
tool so Elsa's immortality could
actually put the people who are most
precious to her in mortal danger you
don't want me to follow you into fire
then don't run into fire it's not just
romantic partners that could be used
against Elsa in the same way her family
could be - that's everyone from Anna and
Kristoff to their kids and Olaf Anna and
Kristoff family could be held as ransom
by an enemy just like any mortal love
interests could be used as a pawn in the
enemies game but would Olaf stand apart
from Elsa's mortal family members could
he also be immortal - we have to wonder
what Olaf's fate will be now that Elsa
is an immortal she created him after all
and when she frozen out of Holland
Olaf's own fate was sealed
but since water has memory Olaf was able
to reform when Elsa became the new
version of herself does this now mean
that he is on the same level as Elsa in
the living forever stakes that would
make Olaf an important ally for Elsa in
the next installment of their story but
we think Elsa could have an even more
powerful collaborator in frozen three
that we haven't met yet no we're done
we can't help but think that Disney will
introduce a new central character to the
third movie it's just the kind of fresh
approach that will give for nude energy
to the next installment and that new
character will surely be important for
Elsa she's finally found her true self
and her true place in the enchanted
forest and that's all really positive
but we can't help but think that Elsa
will have moments when she still feels
really lonely after all Elsa's sing
about wanting to find someone out there
who's a little bit like her in her big
song into the unknown and she's now in a
unique position as an immortal spirit in
human form sure she has the other four
elemental spirits but they're not in
human form and sure she has other humans
like honey Marin and Anna but they're
not immortal spirits so we would love to
see another immortal spirit in human
form
just like Elsa joined the lineup and we
would love it even more if Elsa formed a
romantic partnership with this new
character they would be able to face the
dangers together and work as a
partnership to defeat whatever evil
forces threatens the Enchanted Forest
and arendelle but who could this new
ally be where would they come from there
is so much more to learn about the north
older tribe that we can't help but think
that there's the perfect origin story
for this new character said to be a
bridge between us and the magic of
nature in show yourself Elsa sings about
the reason she'd been pulled to odda
Hollin she wonders if it's her destiny
and the reason she was born she learns
about her parents relationship their
fate and where her magic powers come
from there are different views about the
voice that called Elsa on this journey
some think it's her mother I do not
while others think it's Elsa herself
whichever story you believe Elsa's mom
is the key to her immortality we learned
that the nature spirits reported I do
know for her selfless act of saving a
ganar by giving her a magical daughter
so wouldn't it be wonderful if Elsa's
immortality could allow her to
communicate with her mom and her dad to
in some way perhaps she will discover
extra powers in the third movie after
all water has memory and Elsa's ice
powers are tied up with water so maybe
she can travel back through frozen water
to the Past in
mortal state and visit her parents we've
got chills just thinking about it what
do you think else's immortality will
mean for frozen 3 will it be helpful or
hindrance and what romantic relationship
are you shipping for Elsa let us know in
the comments section alas only Asha
Hollen knows ah - Han please give us a
big thumbs up and remember to hit that
subscribe button to be the first to
watch our latest videos thanks for
watching